what is most important for kids to learn
at school our commitment it isn't about
knowledge acquisition anymore and it
isn't about standards or things that you
need to cover to get all kids to kind of
know what they're supposed to know
because there's too much to be known I
mean we keep in reinventing whole fields
of science and so how is it that we can
say what you need to know is a ten year
old to be successful when you're 40
we've no idea so what we need instead is
to focus and be committed to these
habits so habits like systems thinking
critical thinking and problem-solving
being able to know yourself and develop
that emotional intelligence and
self-regulation skills and then develop
those collaboration skills and theory of
mind to work with other people
developing perspective-taking and then
that enables you to be an effective
member of a group and work as part of a
team so you can then galvanize people
and develop into leadership right
develop into being initiate and solve
problems so there's these kind of
capacities in in that regard these
habits of mind that is the commitment
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Sathyan we
are in the beautiful Winchester
Massachusetts we are at a Sarah school
and we're going to be talking about the
schools and education of the future we
have Courtney Dickinson joining us on
the show hello hi thanks so much for
coming on the show really appreciate it
well thank you for being here it's such
a pleasure Courtney is the founder and
director of a Sarah school which is a
non-profit steam school serving high
ability students in grades K through 8
their mission is to inspire children to
become the problem solvers innovators
creative thinkers and leaders of
tomorrow catalyzing education innovation
around the world they believe that
school should catalyze students passions
free their potential and inspire a sense
of purpose and their motto is the
Massachusetts School of Science
creativity and leadership and you can
find a Sarah school.org in the link in
the bio as well as additional links to
them and Courtney I'm so excited to
cover the subject it's been super fun
having a tour of the school seeing the
Innovation Lab the tech hub the
kids that are just absorbing the
cutting-edge science and creativity and
leadership skills of the future here you
got a hundred thirty of them running
around here it's super fun seeing it
let's start things off we'll get to all
of the great nuance of it I love
starting things off by asking the people
that we feature about what their
thoughts are about the direction of our
world wow that's a big question
well obviously I think about everything
through the lens of the next generation
who will make the world hopefully better
right and I think something that's so
important is that our this next
generation of young people really feel
empowered and knowledgeable and skillful
and really really brave to attack things
and solve problems because you know
we've got a lot of messes we've got a
lot of messes with climate with
diplomacy there's an unending
opportunity to work on health and
well-being and these are the people who
can help us with that and so we need to
be really conscious and intentional
about what experiences they're having
and the habits they're patterning from
throughout their childhood and in school
and outside of school so they can be the
people who they're gonna need to be to
help our world and also so that they can
become the best version of themselves so
we want to create habits and patterns
that are then when they show up on the
scene as a 35 year old and a 55 year old
they're there they're rockin and rollin
so I think that we we have a world with
a lot a lot of really big challenges
that don't have answers and so we need
we need students who are used to asking
big questions struggling with hard
things having things not work coalescing
all kinds of different information and
figure out what is relevant and matters
and and having the courage to try
something even if it's not clear what
that right answer will be so that's just
because the world needs needs that we
need them yes I love how you talk about
it from a perspective of patterns and
habits how do we get the patterning
inhabiting of wanting to explore what
their intrinsic motivations are
having the tool sets and the resources
around them to fulfill those interests
of them to tackle some of these hardest
challenges that we face to figure out
how to have a global cohesion around
moving forward into this exponential
technology age there's so many critical
things that you're outlining here and
acerra schools totally is doing exactly
that and so it doesn't make sense that
you're also trying to scale this out to
public education around the world and
your journey is also very interesting
because you went you went to Dartmouth
and then you did culture architecture at
Sapien corporation you were the founder
of culture solutions a teacher corporate
executive consultant but you were really
inspired by finding your own children a
cutting-edge curriculum in schools so
when I was in college I also got
certified to be a teacher so I'm
certified for kindergarten to grade
eight I thought that's what I would do
and I kind of you know I had a lot of
friends getting jobs in investment
banking and and finance and and I kind
of had this sort of seemingly humble
desire to be a teacher and because I
wanted to make the world better and it
was tough to get jobs you know I looked
for a long time I had a position and I
kind of ended up by accident at a
software company but it was a company
that actually imbued the things that I
believed in for education in schools in
a corporate setting it just had a
different word so instead of calling it
cooperative learning it called it
team-based projects right and there was
an amazing opportunity to really think
about how to enable adults to take the
perspective of other people as they
created software systems to not just
make it cool but actually make it
relevant for the clients needs and then
that turned into a whole journey of five
years they're creating experience of
learning programs that thousands of
people went through and then I created
my own company to do that work for 10
years and for high-growth organizations
and one of the patterns that I saw so
often was that it is it's always hard
for people to develop their emotional
intelligence and self-regulation and
self-awareness skills this is
tough our whole lives yes and another
huge pattern I saw was how often adults
we're not able to think at a systems
level we see our own issue and the own
problems and we think the grass is
greener and so just this awareness of
wow we really need to start early with
developing that emotional intelligence
and developing that system's thinking
skill back when I've been in college I
thought oh one day maybe I'll found my
own school after my kids go to college
and then you know had children and it
was it was it was really going very very
badly the mismatch between at that time
my son was you know young in school as
kindergarten first grade the mismatch
between what he needed and what was
happening in school was so dramatic and
just he had extraordinary potential but
it was really struggling and to realize
the gosh if I don't actually engage he
could he could do amazing things in the
world or he might end up in prison which
sounds kind of like a joke but I'm
completely serious and I think that
really what you want school to be is a
place where kids can actually know their
strengths and identify for their
strengths and then use that to shore up
their weaknesses we all have weaknesses
and have an individual approach for how
that happens if it's them and you know
they're all unique but we need to have
schools be places where there isn't a
ceiling put on them in terms of
developing what they can and if the kid
loves math and is wondering about
negative exponents when they're 7 we
need to have a platform where they can
actually engage on that because that kid
may be a kid who when they're 37 can
really come up with something unique
around climate change and everybody has
their passion and everybody has
strengths so let's create schools where
kids can actually identify and flourish
in those areas of strength and then work
on whatever it is they need to work on
because some kids when they don't have
that chance they have this voracious
desire they maybe it's distractible or
impulsive or they just need to learn
hands-on that what ends up happening is
they actually turn it on themselves or
they turn out on each other and school
becomes a place where they become
depressed anxious they refused to go to
school so we actually this crisis of
what's going on in education that kids
all over even in incredible public
school districts we have kids who are
facing just tremendous issues of
depression and anxiety all through
school you know middle school high
school said I'm starting at ten what and
we need to really take a hard look at
ourselves as adults and has educators
and as a society what are we doing in
school that's making this worse and of
course we've got the news right we've
parentis school shootings we've got
climate change we've got of course it's
gonna create anxiety but what are we
doing in schools that we can change so
that we actually get the best of kids we
really create a path where they can
thrive and have a sense of purpose at
school so what they're learning is
meaningful because right now we don't
mean to but what we're doing is we're
sending this message that's kind of like
become this cultural norm you say oh
it's so sad it's you've only got two
more weeks and you have to go back to
school
enjoy those last days of summer you know
hahaha and it's kind of like a shared
bonding that's of course school is
terrible you know and we're not we don't
even it's like we don't realize we're
doing it when in fact this privilege
this time in our lives when our number
one focus is developing ourselves and
our skills learnt and figuring things
out is kids are innately curious this is
an amazing gift let's let it be that in
school every day for every child that's
possible it is possible for kids to have
a deep sense of purpose to know that
what they're learning and why it matters
to be able to initiate a project and do
passion projects in school and solve
problems that are relevant in their
community we so you know going to a
bunch of different school districts
superintendent school committees mayor's
trying to found a school with these
ideals of hands-on projects open-ended
problem solving systems thinking skill
development early and deep exposure to
stem topics because that's the world
we're in they need to just take on this
goes
kids can understand so much more than
what we give them credit
yes and so if we put it in early they
just they become facile they just soak
it up and they get it it's amazing what
they can do and figure out if we give
them a chance right yes so I tried to
get this going inside a different public
school districts it kept not being able
to happen for a variety of reasons and
and there was a sense that it wasn't a
realistic goal and then I was really sad
to realize I need it I'm so committed to
public education and so we're all the
teachers who work here and the families
who come to this school are also really
deeply saddened by the fact that they
left public education because their kids
needs weren't getting mattered it
couldn't be the teacher they wanted to
be so we had to do something different
so what I realized was we needed to
become a catalyst for change outside the
system yes instead of inside and so here
we are and now we're a decade into this
journey of having a school that is this
vibrant organism and kids it every time
new people come in and new hires come in
they they're stunned
you know we announce the snow day or you
know we're not going to school because
it's a report card writing and then even
the middle schoolers are sad about not
coming to school you know in the kids
negotiate with their parents can we
please schedule this appointment so I
don't miss my philosophy elective I want
to be a school and this is a kid who
never wanted to go to school his entire
life and now for the first time you know
joining our schools a sixth grader
because what he's learning is really
interesting and it's really relevant and
he gets to do a debate and put put a
revolution on trial and find out if
actually it was a real revolution and
learn you know so there's there's ways
to bring this alive in all schools and
and our commitment is to show it's
possible by being here and being a
microcosm of that and then figure out
which approaches are portable into
public education that it it isn't about
money it's about approach
it's about philosophy and we've really
started to do that work and
and that's been our goal the whole time
is is bring that into public schools and
share with them what was possible you
had a need to fill and it was the old
code that is present in the existing
educational infrastructure is archaic
and it needed to be updated and
sometimes you have to almost now it
seems to be always you have to go
outside of the system build something a
new mental models possible prove
something different is possible and you
can update the old educational code by
obsoleting it with this new code this
new system and so I love that you had
that passion to start school yourself to
prove that and then furthermore you gave
us these examples of ok a kid is super
passionate about a subject when they're
7 years old why is there a limiting
weiser ceiling on that subject
that's ridiculous this child explored of
the desires should be fulfilled no
matter which part of the edge they want
to go to and exploring keep pushing then
you use two other words that I think are
super important here you used two other
thoughts one of them was self-awareness
so to be able to foster whatever that
unique DNA is of that child to have
their fruits be fully come alive in the
world is critical and so it requires
them to be able to play and figure out
who they are and have other mentors and
teachers community parents helping them
fully realize that and also systems
thinking so actually understanding that
the humans just like you jammed between
the crazy atoms and molecules and the
solar systems and the cosmos so it's
just this what are these systems and the
design of civilization that we live in
and how do we get that to a child's mind
at a very young age and you Eve even
you've even put together over 10 years
this has developed this idea of
transforming education having these
intrinsic motivations we explore these
real world
Proms be tackled steam but not only
science technology engineering art and
math for everyone but specifically also
for young girls and in the ten tools to
transform schools so it's both behind
your head as well as here and we're
gonna have a nice digital embed of this
as well for you to check out as we
continue unpacking this throughout I
love this creativity and
systems-thinking leadership in EQ
Sciences and innovation this is so
beautiful
so yes so walk us through this sort of
21st century toolkit these you have
these course so so the backdrop behind
that is that what is most important for
kids to learn at school
our commitment it isn't about knowledge
acquisition anymore and it isn't about
standards or things that you need to
cover to get all kids to kind of know
what they're supposed to know because
there's too much to be known I mean we
keep in reinventing whole fields of
science and so how is it that we can say
what you need to know as a ten-year-old
to be successful when you're 40 we've no
idea so what we need instead is to focus
and be committed to these habits so
habits like systems thinking critical
thinking and problem solving
being able to know yourself and develop
that emotional intelligence and
self-regulation skills and then develop
those collaboration skills and theory of
mind to work with other people
developing perspective-taking and then
that enables you to be an effective
member of a group and work as part of a
team so you can then galvanize people
and develop into leadership right
develop into being able initiate and
solve problems so there's these kind of
capacities in in that regard these
habits of mine that is the commitment
when you free yourself up from thinking
you're supposed to cover a certain set
of content right that's been an old
debate about is there a canon of
knowledge it tended to be to Western
well there there isn't there there's we
also can free ourselves up from thinking
the teacher has to know all of that and
teach it to kids so what we need to do
instead is redefine the role of teachers
to say that there
job is to facilitate the students to
have discovery and learning in the
classroom through experiences that
matter to the kids right now this is a
very different job so the role of the
teacher becomes much less about teaching
specific things and becomes much more
about asking the right questions and
then coaching into where kids are and
then bringing the right resources in so
bring in the thought leaders beam in the
scientists who can talk about why this
application of CRISPR to edit gene is to
edit a gene is appropriate with what's
happening in the landscape of genomics
and life sciences I don't have to know
that as a teacher and and once you can
free yourself up from an identity that
is about courses and coverage suddenly
you're actually focused on what's going
to engage kids and that they actually
end up retaining much more of the skills
and the knowledge when it's been when
they've learned it in a context where
they have meaningful projects they're
working on so I think there are but it's
it's kind of like it's just it's a
reframe and in that reframe is a massive
amount of freedom for teachers and
students to capitalize on what's present
for for each kid to engage authentically
yeah and one of these keys that you said
is that the teacher teachers and parents
and community mentors are facilitating
discovery for young people the awareness
expansions these experiences for young
people to be able to fully realize what
they want to learn and what they want to
do in our world and just these these
transformative tools that you have here
I think are what we need around the
world to become more I know you said
cannon isn't necessarily the right way
of perceiving it but at the same time we
need to just be blunt and honest that
leadership in EQ just absolutely matters
it is just it's what matters yeah you
know science and innovation how do you
come up with the solutions to the
problems if we're not focused on that
and creativity system thinking so the
science of the absence of creativity
isn't real science and I've learned that
from some of the incredible curriculum
collaborators we've worked with over the
years but one of the you know so you'd
said you asked me earlier to unpack
these different yes so so one of the
core ideas that I think could happen at
every school is this idea of an
individual learning plan for every
student so it fits their interests their
potential and the end their and their
needs so their unique learning profile
and dynamic so it can adjust their
interests change so at the start of the
year doing assessments for kids not
stressful assessments some of them are
observational they're qualitative
they're not timed to find out where what
is a child next ready to learn or do in
writing in reading in math in emotional
intelligence and perspective-taking
and then that core classroom teacher can
work with that student and their parents
to come up with the right individual
learning plan it fits appropriate
learning goals for them this year the
most complicated learning goals are
usually around the emotional
intelligence realm right so so that's a
really core concept one of the things
that then links to that just as an
example is having an ability based math
block so in our school we have kids take
math at the same time as each other so
that based upon the evaluations of where
kids are what their next ready for and
their learning style they can be put
into a math group they switch classes
and everybody's on on deck to teach math
not everybody but a lot of teachers are
teaching math so it isn't just the math
teacher teaches math and that's probably
the most traditional part of our school
because it's a hour-long class but that
way if kids are more project-based
learners and need a really deeply
applied approach in this kind of third
fourth grade set of things that they
should be learning then they can be in
another group of kids who learn best
with that type of approach and then we
also call this multi age yes these are
all so the classrooms themselves are
multi age the learning in the core
classroom is around a theme with
essential questions and lots of projects
woven in some of which are pre-planned
that a teacher knows it
going to happen some of which are
spontaneous based upon a student's idea
and but then in the math class they are
there they can also be working
potentially above grade level or even
substantially above grade level whatever
that means anyways to fit what they're
ready for so they're not held back when
you're getting another powerful thing in
the core classroom if you doing
open-ended projects that are around
themes and essential questions then
let's you know gosh what's a good
example in let's say the theme for the
year this is an example from a third and
fourth grade classroom a couple years
ago the themes for the year were around
climate change in the industrial
revolution so kids were doing research
about different aspects of climate
change they ended up picking a
particular topic they were passionate
about it really cared about they were
they've got into groups they came up
with answers to climate change they
created you know a model they did a
report they did a PowerPoint they did
some persuasive writing and they kind of
published newspaper articles and then
they did kind of an expo where their
parents came in and got to rotate around
and have each student pitch this is
what's going on and climate change these
are some of our answers this is some of
the relevant research and current work
but these are some of our creative
solutions so these kids are you know
eight nine and ten an incredibly FAFSA
with all the complexities now this
project happened over the course of
months right and it touches every
subject area science is related to
writing is related to persuasive
speaking is related to representing
things in pictorial and movie and
different formats and is meaningful so
then if I as a student struggle with
organization and writing I'm really
motivated to work on that because I want
to make my pitch about why we've got to
address this issue with co2 release from
cars or too many cows and you know that
we need to address the issue with with
that I'm passionate about it and
suddenly I actually start to care about
applying these strategies that my
teachers coaching me on for writing in a
coherent way because I need to I need to
convince people that this should be
different that's a couple quick
questions okay
so within the class rooms within the
school there is both of the multi-age as
well as the different learning style so
ones that want to gravitate towards a
specific style of learning can engage
with other students no matter which age
in that specific style of learning and
then there's also the peer to peer
mentorship and the working together on
parts that they may not understand they
can get assistance with then I also
really loved the multi month project
based on a real-world problem real a
problem and then being able to work on
the skills of the persuasive speaking
writing science all mashed together and
then when it's so interesting because
then when they when they're getting out
actually into the world they're speaking
about those things they're they're
working on those projects so it it seems
to basically take potentially a list of
the top ten challenges that society
faces and have kids do project-based
work in the family real challenges of
our time yeah so themes that you see
coming up over and over again in our
school are around climate and
sustainability and environment you see
that just comes up across all the time
kids bring it up in our kind of world
geography and interconnected in this
elective and middle school they end up
doing these pitches about about that
another huge thing that comes up all the
time is inclusion social justice and
voice and courage to address those needs
and issues and and how we can be we can
initiate change and be activists in
those ways and those themes again touch
all over the place so another example
that's going on right now in a grade to
three class room in the building they
have a this SolarCity
box project so it's box city it's kind
of what it is so they're creating these
cute little boxes their little you know
their adorable children making things
three-dimensional very very cute okay
they're also making them solar they're
planning out the whole community
and then they get into campaigns so what
is you know kids are making persuasive
speeches about part of our climate
commitment and contract in our city will
be this and then they pitch to each
other the ideas of what they want
represented in these tenants that they
then have to agree to so they're getting
real world problems persuasive speaking
have to back up their ideas with
evidence then and then they need to come
up with an agreement together this is
really hard but this is absolutely real
world and then they're building these
beautiful beautiful things that they
love and are excited and they're
measuring them and they're making them
to scale and they're modeling them and
they're thinking of all the different
people who would live there and how so
that's you know that's another example
of a real-world project and I think the
power is that me is the head of the
school I'm not going in and saying oh oh
you know you're supposed to be on this
page or you're supposed to be covering
this content that was a natural
outgrowth of interest that the kids had
passion that the teacher has and and
then they can weave in again write the
writing and the coaching and the
learning that needs to happen in context
in a way that really gives power and
freedom and autonomy the teacher and yes
that student may write a longer sort of
research persuasive piece about why this
needs to be one of the tenants then that
starts student this because they're in
different places so all open-ended
meaningful projects that are long-term
are a natural kind of format for
differentiated instruction to occur in a
classroom and you just create language
for you know a student might say how
come you're really encouraging me to
write a whole page about this topic and
you know you're only encouraging him to
write three sentences and very quickly
the teacher can just say because you can
you're able to do that and the student
says okay you know and so it very I
think that's one of the fears we can
have is that if we have different
assignments or different expectations
for kids that it's not fair they lugal
batter it's not consistent but
consistency is actually the wrong goal
the the real goal should be knowing
yourself knowing your own limitations
your own strengths
being able to ask for help where your
week growing where your week and that
there's again there's freedom in that so
kids by the end of being here at school
you know we had a student one year at
the kind of they create their own
graduation um she gave a speech and she
said well you know I'm still not I when
I came here I wasn't great with social
cues and I didn't have a lot of friends
and it was really really disorganized
she was I mean my stuff isn't totally
organized and together now
but if he's does not flying off into the
sunset right it's 150 people sitting
there everybody laughs she's she's good
timing she's funny she's you know and
you just see that kind of acceptance of
self yeah and the courage that that
brings then she can advocate when she
gets to high school hey these are kind
of supports I need for my profile and
this is what I can offer so that kind of
constant development of emotional
intelligence and self-regulation in all
kinds of ways so when a teacher is doing
this work let's say there's a they're
doing a unit on marble around magnetism
and electricity and creating a game
using these components I'm playing with
those materials so when the teacher is
working with kids
the teacher is just as likely to coach
into where those kids are with creating
that game about taking turns with ideas
and doing active listening as they are
to really think about how the magnetism
works and how the electricity works so
that kind of constantly going back and
forth between the teaching and the
coaching around emotional intelligence
and that metacognition level is woven in
all the time across every topic every
day and that's a method of learning
that's one of the tools in our toolkit
about self-regulation and emotional
intelligence growth yes yes so that's I
wanted to hit on that and just on the
weight of that there was there's there's
this interesting balance that seems to
need to be struck when talking about
consistency and an uniqueness because we
have yeah because we have this unique
DNA that we want every child to express
to their fullest their full creative
potential their own fruits that they can
bring to our world while simultaneously
there's some sort of a level of
basic language that needs to be learned
to communicate between humans just these
types of things right so so there's kind
of a little balance there also as you
were as you're speaking it it not only
does it then make sense to take on in
something like a do you do this in your
in your in your in in in pretty much in
high school when you're finishing
classes in college when you're fishing
classes when you're doing a thesis right
you you're basically taking something on
that you're fascinated with and that
you're doing a presentation a summary of
what so to be able to do something like
your own graduation project is something
that seems to be really exciting
engaging you started hitting on the
emotional intelligence of
perspective-taking
how it's basically embedded in the
conversations like the turn taking this
type of stuff give us some more of these
emotional intelligence EQ examples yeah
okay so another example where there's
concurrence between academic learning
and growth with this kind of emotional
intelligence growth would be you know
clack classic examples in a math class
where one of the tricky things as kids
can get into habit of thinking that the
purpose of school and be in class is to
show what they know when in fact we want
them to be in a habit of showing that
they can learn which is very different
so part of what was a breakthrough its
breakthrough for many kids is when you
know they're ready maybe for some say
some algebra content but their
organizational skills and their writing
skills aren't yet solid enough for them
to be able to express that we need to
proactively teach growth mindset what
that is what it looks like what it
doesn't look like and give them phrases
and then wow they're then trying to
learn how to write out things we go back
and forth with as math coaches and math
teachers to say okay this is how you do
this now remember you need to show me
that you're able to stick with it even
when it's difficult that you're asking
for help where you're struggling that
you are
yeah you're showing what you don't know
because then you're coachable to learn
new things and so you can that expressly
was taught that was a breakthrough
moment for my son in particular when he
was a 7th grader when that was taught in
new ways and then he said okay got it
he started his frontal lobe starts to
come in he's able to have a little bit
more self regulation it's so much better
to do at seventh right seventh grade as
adults right but that was the bracelet
for him is really manifesting growth
mindset concurrent with learning algebra
that he was able to get to a whole new
level as a mathematician which he was
very motivated about but the
self-regulation is much harder for most
people so that's that's one example
another example is in a literature book
club group that part of what you're
doing in that conversation is not just
talking about text attacks connections
and the characters and the development
and the rise and fall of the storyline
and storyboarding but you're also
talking about the emotional life of the
character and the complexities that
they're getting it and then you might
even use those as analogies for some
conflicts kids have had on the
playground at the school and then you
can pop out of the conversation about
the book to maybe do some conflict
resolution that fits real life you know
and you then can also get on the balcony
of the conversation to not just have the
conversation but also talk about how
you're having the conversation so kids
are really developing skill in their
conversation while they're in their
literature book club group again so
you're getting into metacognitive level
concurrently these are things teachers
know how to do can do and I think when
you free them up from thinking it's
about coverage or being in a certain
place then they have time to do that
deeper work so that that's those are
those are two examples I can go on and
on with examples most intelligence
concurrent with academic growth yes and
to be able to identify things like the
importance of a growth mindset and grit
and perspective taking in these
emotional intelligence skills at very
young age is critical and I'm so in love
with the
the tenth tool to transform schools oh
this is so great and I want to now I
want to I want to move us into how
you're also not only doing this at a
Sarah for the 130 students here but
you're taking this to transform public
schools around the United States and
hopefully around the world that's our
goal
yeah so yeah I know I love it yeah it is
small I love it the big goals yeah yeah
yeah no no small goal I love it yeah I
love it and it's definitely time for it
and okay so let's talk about how they're
you're doing these public school teacher
trainings and you were blowing my mind
when you were even saying that Oh life
sciences education let's have the kids
start doing gene editing with CRISPR I
was like I was like that's what's up
let's get to that level yeah so we're
really um you know it's incredible that
we're here in Boston so close to so much
incredible innovation in ends in the
science technology engineering fields
and so when I founded the school a
commitment from the beginning was let's
leverage that let's have thought
partners who are really innovating and
their field to come into the school
let's bring them in and figure out how
to weave together learning with what is
happening in the world that is relevant
optics engineering for climate change
you know
CRISPR and gene editing technology for
Life Sciences and health human health
but then the fact that we're so lucky to
be able to do that let's figure out
that's that's up the ante and also come
up with an approach which could scale to
other schools so over these last years
in our life sciences lab that is a lab
based approach we have been pilot
testing a whole bunch of different
hands-on science units then when you put
them together there's now 11 units that
we are ready to really translate align
to standards and bring into the public
school space to really reinvent the way
life sciences education is happening now
we're bootstrapping that again a little
bit so when I founded the school I knew
how to galvanize people I don't have any
money I founded it with a PowerPoint in
a promise and go into public libraries
and here we are you know proving that
this is possible even though we didn't
have any money to get going and so but
now with the education innovation work
we're in a little bit of that same
face again because we can't help
ourselves there's such a sense of
justice and fairness about every kid
should be able to engage hands-on in
science class doing real work in this
way so we went ahead and we created a
life science change agent workshop
series and we had our first one in the
winter we had three days we we have you
know educators from seven different
school districts were part of that first
ever workshop training and now those
teachers are in their high school
biology classrooms running experiments
kids are having that experience of
editing a gene with CRISPR having the
conversation around what this means it
is linked to next generation science
standards about what they should be
learning which gives teachers permission
to spend time on this hands-on lab
instead of worrying that they're not
covering what they're kind of obligated
to cover and and then they have the
conversation about ethics around it part
of what we were able to do in that day
was bring the kids into a life sciences
company where they actually talked to
scientists who are doing this research
and learning so that teachers can these
science teachers are so excited to link
learning to real-world innovation but
they need help they want the support so
this is we have our next cohort groups
starting at next month in the end of
June and this is the kind of thing we
look to we would grow to have many
cohorts and to be able to add on all
these other units the next you know
we're adding is about skin microbiome
sampling within the context of skin
microbiome sampling over time you can
actually see evolution happening within
your own skin microbiome incredibly cool
and there are so many other things that
can be taught about that in the data
tracking so that's one example another
example is the stem coordinator a stem
director in the low public schools which
is a urban School District about 45
minutes north of Austin came and sought
us out a couple years ago then we were
able to bring a whole group of school
leaders including a bunch of their
principals from that district into our
building in the fall and we were really
thinking that we'd end up focusing on
they kind of the initial request was hey
we want to start a makerspace we hear
you have a lot of makerspace stuff can
we come into your school
and so now what we've turned it into is
that group of leaders came from that
school district and they said wow we
don't want to just do different
makerspace things you're doing
we're should we do all were doing and so
what we've been able to define is a
three-year whole school transformation
effort where over the course we'd start
with some of these units we call them
seeds science storytelling engineering
we're connecting up different
electronics and design and packing with
electricity and and micro computers and
robotics to make this so there's a right
answer but they're but you're tethering
together imagination and story and
creating something that's beautiful with
design process and prototyping and
making mistakes and fixing it to stem
tools so this is a really powerful this
particular program this seeds makerspace
program can really start with kids at
age five it goes up through grade 12 and
it's a really wonderful way to capture
girls into these stem topics early so
our kind of our innovator who has is
kind of the lead person in that area of
our school is from the MIT Media Lab she
used to be a fashion designer she was
briefly a medical school she did all
these things and she actually came from
India to the MIT Media Lab with the goal
of coming up with low-cost ways for this
to happen so it could be scalable
so that's always in our minds eye of how
to do things that our makerspace related
that can be scaled so so that was that's
the start but these things can all link
to standards they link to story they
link to writing a link to math right and
so that's what we're going to do we just
did our first unit with that with this K
to 8 school that we're going to do this
three or effort for last week and their
entire staff was there for this training
learning how to do toy hacking
learning how to do there were there were
a few other stations we had with them
one was I think about tech hub and
respectful disassembly where you're
getting in and understanding things and
and then hacking them and creating new
things out of it and that you just loved
it so so they started off I mean you
know it's it's they want to go home it's
and then they they really their face is
lit up
they love these opportunities and we
made it you make it doable to bring this
in you don't have to know all the
answers as a teacher but you're creating
hands-on learning so that seeds is kind
of one of these these 10 tools for
schools that then is an entry point for
a whole bunch of other things that can
get you can get computer science
tethered to that we have a whole
computers and me curriculum for K to
Grade three that includes some seed
stuff some physical computing and tech
hub take apart but a cute idea within
that is that within thinking about the
different communication styles that
exist in all people and things a
computer you learned that you need to
best communicate with someone else the
way that works for them and one of those
things is that as a computer so then you
think about logic based communication
yes and then you back into starting to
you be some of these basic computer
science ideas and our logic loops around
you know drag-and-drop interfaces for
young kids using scratch using other
tools so that is connecting up against
social-emotional learning with computer
science education so that's another one
of our sectors is computer science and
that's one example of the kinds of
curriculum we've been doing here that we
want to bring alive you guys are totally
systems thinkers and you can tell by the
way that you speak it's like you don't
just to know how to speak to other
humans based on how well what they works
for them in terms of communication style
but how do you communicate with
computers how do you communicate with
other natural systems like animals in
our world and then further it was so
cool hearing you talk about how it's
taking this your 10 tools to transform
schools and being able to bring that to
other low-income or urban schools and
slowly get teachers that come to the
sessions going like whoa yes well these
are the types of things that we need
around the world across the difference
across these different subjects fields
plus also taking that and kind of you're
doing the slow getting to the different
schools one at a time in person but also
to do things like be able to
include conversations that are currently
being had at the United Nations level at
the corporations around the world that
are some of the largest ones around
things like ethics around CRISPR
technologies right around genetic
engineers don't run up the whole chain
to really capture all these different
kinds of learners because some if the
meaning and the context that is really
big is what's gonna make them then focus
on the details right but also you need
to do that to set them up to be the
citizens and innovators for the world
who we need
so it's you've got to run up and down
the whole the whole playing field yes
yes and - I'm really looking forward to
also there's a lot of digital up
potential as well a lot of what we do is
I - I face-to-face you know small small
group multi-age right in the in the
communities and learning simultaneously
if you if there is more and more
potential for having an internet
connection and a computer from around
the world to be able to get other
teachers from around the world scale
this yes it's a huge part of what we
think about I think that the thing that
we are doing that were starting to pilot
test and it's it's kind of a philosophy
the thing that's the most scalable the
most quickly I would say is this notion
of a school success dashboard so a lot
of schools are starting to think a
little bit about that back in the 90s we
called it a balanced scorecard approach
that it's not just profitability for a
company well the analogy for schools is
that it isn't just standardized testing
of basic literacy basic math and then
absences we need to be tracking there
are other things we we kids need to be
learning we need to have new ways to
measure those things and we need to as
these adults on point for the this next
generation hold ourselves accountable
for more than just these basic skills so
what are the ways that we can track
collaboration skill development over
time so working with Peter Blake who's a
developmental psychologist at the BU
social learning lab that we have a
system thinking game which can also be
used as a collaboration skill assessment
tool so that's something that we're
looking at could we translate this and
grow this that's one example another
example is one of our partners is an MIT
Dalai Lama Center
and should focus on self awareness and
mindfulness and ethics and ethical
decision-making right but they've but
there's a tool that they've developed
that we started a pilot test it with our
kids here which is kind of self
awareness about emotional states and
it's kind of one way to think about it
if you roll that up it's a marker for
happiness right so that's the kind of
thing we'd love to see a happiness
marker populate a school success
dashboard that we're looking at across
schools all over because we have kids
even you know whether it's because of
fear of gun violence or not having
breakfast before school or they're
buried under a tremendous amount of
homework and pressure you know that's
the kind of the misery of school so I
may be performing well by my
standardized test scores but if I'm
miserable I'm not that is not there
isn't there isn't a tracking and
accountability for well-being so we're
trying to figure out what would those
measures be and how can we change the
conversation everywhere about what
matters in school and add new measures
that we can collect data around so I
think happiness and that's really real
and I think I think we all kind of know
that from our own experience but then
once you have a child who's in school
who's miserable I think your sense of
urgency around this topic just escalates
in such a dramatic way but if we can
have you know come up with five key
measures and even if we start having a
groundswell of students who are saying
my happiness matters this is what's
going on yes I'm a straight-a student at
whatever great you know high school but
I'm miserable and I'm upset it's it's
it's a big deal so there's some health
surveys that are required by law to do
there's a tracking around that so one of
the local ones that was through the
Lahey Health Center they did some mental
health tracking and they check habits
risk youth behavior risk survey and one
of them is around
and incidents of that and incidents of
kids who are thinking about and have
kind of created a plan for suicide the
numbers are shocking we need to we need
to look at that and we need to start
measuring that in a systematic way and
we need to start really thinking about
that and one of the answers for that I
think we put into our self kind of
emotional regulation is is probably
around intentionally and I think lots of
people talk about this but it's about
doing it right embedding mindfulness and
strategies for that into school it's
there's some incredible data that's come
out about a difference it makes but you
need to also pair that with reducing
homework loads so if you look at what's
indicated by there isn't a ton of
research about it but what is you know
what's the amount of numbers of hours of
homework you should have in middle
school in high school a lot of kids are
having three and four hours of homework
a night which is counter productive it's
actually helpful and I've you know I
think the American Academy of Pediatrics
in some of their research they're really
saying you reach diminishing returns
anyways after two hours yet it's almost
like a badge if I'm in a good school or
a badge for a teacher sometimes or the
risk is that parents will say they mean
more homework to be ready and it's the
wrong like let's actually track those
hours and let's have a goal be set that
matches with the literature about what's
healthy for these children so there's
you know but that's another it's a
massive opportunity to change what we're
defining as the purpose of school if
we're saying part of the purpose of
school is to help kids be able to filter
lots of information to know what's most
important and salt and coalesce
complicated ideas to initiate and solve
problems then we need to change the way
school happens because it's not about
time to test it's not about showing the
work the way that that you were told
it's but that could be that's scalable
we could start there we can have a
different conversation altogether yeah
and to be able to have breathing space
for creativity and exploration is
critical and also that taking something
like the ten tools to transform
wasn't taking that - in scaling it
around the world to get at least the
essences of the importance of emotional
intelligence and misil because
especially there's so much potential for
places around the world to leapfrog in
terms of the technology stacks so just
as an example it's so interesting to
potentially think about what it would be
like for countries around the world that
are still in the process of developing
themselves economically to be able to to
transform of their their their their
banking and payment infrastructures
through decentralized infrastructures
through the cryptocurrency
infrastructures other things like could
they potentially start genetic
engineering had even before some of the
advanced more developed nations do you
also mentioned new measurements of
well-being being something that's so
critical we keep seeing this is a
reoccurring theme in the political
discourse around the world that were
kind of sick of just GDP and stock
market of just being the the sole
measures because we see that why are
there what's going on with anxiety and
depression suicide why are those things
so prevalent how are they related to
social media use and how can we just
better be able to apply mindfulness
meditation these sorts of ancient
practices multi thousand-year-old
practices into our lives and lives of
our children to gain us a stronger
global cohesion these are such pressing
themes and I'm I'm looking forward to
continuing to visit what a Sarah is
doing and helping you with scaling these
these these processes these tools these
ways of thinking to people around the
world and and I know that will continue
having more conversations because you're
just so incredible like I loved when you
were talking about the story of like I
was there no one I had a vision no one
really you know ten years ago it's like
I have a PowerPoint of this vision and
it's so hard to you know after ten years
see a school
130 students in it that's badass
well thank you are awesome oh you're
really nice thank you you are so this is
like this is the story that's like a
quintessential story of like 10 years
ago there was a there was a vision
there was nothing sighs a vision
creating something out of nothing
there's no money yeah it's such a
beautiful thank you it's hard work yes
for sure
urines you don't give up you don't give
up give up that's right people keep
saying it's not possible we also have
500 kids to come to our summer programs
and we have an hour after school summer
vacation camp weeks are open to the
public for everybody we started to do a
whole bunch of outreach work to
Cambridge youth programs in you know in
um in Cambridge I mean there's there's
just so many things we're doing to bring
this to other populations yeah you're
you're crushing it I love it I love it
and it's been it's been such a cool time
to be around something else that I hope
people that are watching from around the
world can kind of maybe feel in their
essence is that for those that are maybe
around the age of like 20 to 30 it's so
important for us to go into settings
with young kids because what happens
Joyce it's joy yeah it's so joyous its
blissful you get to be there like
watching kids when kids are learning is
like watching a sponge soak up the world
around it and it's knowledge and and
forming that mind and so and being there
to potentially sit down and help with oh
one you know when that someone's
learning a reading process or an
engineering process a design process
whatever it may be to be there and it's
just it's it's play at its finest and -
and for us to never as adults lose yeah
that playful spirit is another one of
the one of the most fun things is when
you kind of sidle up to a middle
schooler they have four hours a week
they work on passion projects and that's
one of the things that is we'd really
want to share and have happen everywhere
they have a framework and they're
learning on project management they're
doing the research but they're also
inventing something it doesn't matter
what they're doing it could be bring
alive a play do an art project instil a
do a service-learning project make
something but you know this girl comes
to our school and she designs this dress
that's supposed to be really comfortable
and flow and she's had to rebuild it a
couple times and then there's lace
sleeves and she's come up with a way to
light up the sleeves and code that with
Arduino so that it will kind of sparkle
in this pattern she's tried to pin
sensors and some of this work and
something happen and she's you know
she's a sixth grader and she's on fire
yeah and it's just it's it's it's it's
truly awe-inspiring and then the courage
and bravery of that she'll share that
with we're walking around you know we've
got a group of people from Brazil here
today again another group of like 20
people visiting to see what we're doing
and you you just get these kids to pause
it say hey what's your project and they
share it and this is a kid that you're
like oh you know that kid had before
they got here they had big issues with
anxiety but now they're working on
something they picked they're passionate
on all of that falls away and they're
courageous in front of all of these
adults who they don't know to share what
they're doing and the struggles are
having with it and what they figure it
out and what they're hoping they can
they can solve next time it's just it's
like you know this is school you can
make you brave this is education this is
the future of schools and education yeah
Courtney couple really quick questions
on the way out that we like asking I
guess the first question is what would
you say and this is this is interesting
because you have so many of these skills
already listed here but what would you
see is one of the most critical skills
for children as well as even adults to
learn going into this exponential
technology age they're they're totally
interrelated but I'd say self regulation
and perspective taking you need to be
able to manage your own responses to
things and you need to be a and then
that feeds directly then to you being
able to take the perspective of somebody
else because only then can you think
about how the technology will get used
by people who aren't you how they will
affect other cultures what the impact
will be on environment
the perspective-taking that you know
realizing we all have our own myopia and
you need to really seek to understand
points of view that aren't your own so
you can be a responsible inventor and do
good because who cares if you created a
bunch of cool stuff if it doesn't do
something good in the world right
so I'd say perspective taken and then do
you think that we're in a simulation
what do you mean do you think that this
is a simulated reality what of our world
right now that we're in a simulation
well I think you can't live as if it is
because then you'll you can have excuses
for and be irresponsible in your
behavior no I don't think we're living
in a simulation I think we're really
here right now and then what we're doing
actually is making an impact and I think
we can you can complain and you can
absorb what's wrong and you can talk
about what's wrong and you can do
research about what's wrong or you can
step up and you can live in the world
with the belief of hey I'm massively
imperfect there's times I don't have or
don't know but I'm gonna take a stand to
change things and you're not gonna do
that if you think you're in a simulation
but I think I will counter and say that
even if someone does feel like they're
already in a simulated reality they can
still be challenged - well I want to
level up I want to keep I want to be my
best I want to actualize well maybe in
some ways that makes it even easier
because you're not worried about the
consequences in the same way if you're
in a simulation then you're free because
there isn't there really isn't anything
at stake in the same way right but you
have to give yourself you have to give
yourself that own freedom and permission
to make an impact and get rid of the
excuses and get rid of the fear and
figure out what you uniquely have that
you can offer and and go do that and the
last question is what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
I don't know whole bunch of things kind
of mine but humanity when it is good is
breathtaking the generosity of spirit
that sometimes you can see is so
magnificent
you know the acceptance the authentic
acceptance of someone else's apology is
so beautiful
that's one there's many nature and the
Sun I love so I'm a landscape painter so
I love the beauty of nature and the
beauty of shapes and the analogies that
creates
humanity and and nature it's beautiful
Corinne this has been such an honor such
a pleasure thank you
thanks for coming thank you for asking
it's an honor to be invited to sure yes
Sara school is doing incredible work
thank you so much everyone for tuning in
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode also
go and share more conversations about
subjects like these ten tools to
transform schools about emotional
intelligence about science and
innovation creative with creativity and
systems thinking just talk to your
friends your family or coworkers people
on the Internet just go and keep talking
to people and spreading messages check
out all the links below to a sara school
org as well as the other links below
share those as well support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below help us
continue doing cool things like coming
to epic places like a sara school and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world thank you so
much for tuning in and we will see you
soon that's a wrap
thank you you crushed it oh you did so
well I love learning about you and your
stuff oh thank you
it's brilliant it really is fun to have
you here it's like I can go on for hours
I get sidetracked I'm not very good at
Freddy this is only the beginning
yeah yeah and it's very important to
scale this and you're doing that yeah
and we hope to help